[Musique]
vous le reconnaissez ces homo sapiens en
train de frotter son silex pour faire du
feu c'était il ya entre 400 mille et un
million d'années
c'est sans doute le premier pollueur de
la planète vous vous dites que dans
notre monde moderne technologique et
ultra connectés on est bien loin de cet
ancien cousin eh bien non je suis au
regret de vous dire que par bien des
égards nous sommes restés très proches
de lui sapiens a passé son temps à
brûler tout ce qui lui tombait sous la
main
il a commencé avec le bois pour sa
nourriture pour faire des armes mais
aussi pour faire des outils et puis
ensuite il à brûler du charbon du
pétrole ou du gaz pour faire fonctionner
des machines encore plus de machines
tout à combustion
vous voyez on n'est pas encore sorti de
l'ère du feu et kilifeu dit carbone
quand sapiens brûle il aimait du carbone
danse dans l'atmosphère alors ok
aujourd'hui l'image du carbone n'est pas
très reluisante
elle est grise on pense tout de suite
aux mines de charbon au coup de grisou
au changement climatique
mais le carbone c'est la vie il n'y a
pas de vie connue sans carbone et il
peut être magnifique
quand c'est du diamant c'est le
quatrième élément le plus abondant dans
l'univers le 15e élément le plus
abondant sur la terre alors on nous dit
qu'il faut décarbonés notre énergie
c'est vrai mais je pense différemment
je pense qu'on ne peut pas se passer de
carbone il faut revoir l'usagé du
carbone moi j'ai passé vingt ans à faire
de la recherche
et j'ai créé une entreprise qui va
fabriquer du carbone pour faire des
batteries pour les énergies
renouvelables et les véhicules
électriques de demain on veut fabriquer
du carbone sans brûler de carbone à
partir de matières premières bio sur
sable et pourquoi pas de co2 bref on
veut faire des batteries au carbone
zéro carbone le carbone c'est notre bel
a fait notre passé le carbone est très
présent aujourd'hui un petit peu trop
dans l'atmosphère est un petit peu trop
dans ma vie de tous les jours aussi j'en
suis devenu un expert et je pense qu'il
aura une place fondamentale dans notre
futur mais revenons un petit peu en
arrière
prenons une perspective historique si
sapiens a brûlé sans arrêt du carbone et
si nous nous continuons à brûler des
énergies fossiles
c'est parce que c'était facile et c'est
est profitable regardez la corrélation
entre ces deux courbes
vous avez en bleu la courbe de l' indice
de développement humain
c'est une mesure du bien-être mis en
place par l'organisation des nations
unies pour faire simple c'est une mesure
de notre bonheur sur terre moyens et
vous avez en gris le carbone la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par sapiens au cours
du temps vous voyez que ces deux courbes
grimpe en parallèle qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que plus on
consomme de l'énergie
plus on est heureux c'est une valeur
moyenne bien entendu un je ne parle pas
de toutes les inégalités qu'on peut
trouver sur terre en termes de taxes et
à l'énergie et d'accès au bonheur mais
c'est une valeur moyenne qui fonctionne
bien et si vous regardez la courbe de la
population humaine ici en rouge vous
voyez qu'elle grimpe de la même façon
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais ça veut
dire que plus on a utilisé de l'énergie
plus on a rendu des gens heureux autour
de nous et ouais ça marche bien
bien sûr en face de nous se trouve le
mur du changement climatique et vous
avez la courbe jaune ici qui présente
l'augmentation du taux de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
c'est un mur infranchissable toutes ces
coupes sont parallèles ça peut pas durer
c'est plus tenable est-ce qu'on est
obligé de continuer à augmenter notre
consommation d'énergie pour augmenter
notre bonheur au détriment de notre
planète
c'est pas possible il faut trouver autre
chose qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire réduire
notre bonheur revenir au temps passé
j'y crois pas trop réduire la population
j'en parle même pas essayer de mieux
utiliser l'énergie - la gaspiller oui ça
c'est une piste valable mais moi je veux
vous parler de l'utilisation de
nouvelles formes d'énergie qui ne
rejette pas de co2 dans l'atmosphère
bien sûr on veut tous les énergies
renouvelables on veut tous le solaire
les énergies de la mer
l'éolien ce sont des énergies qui à
l'usagé ne rejette pas de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
même si pour beaucoup d'entre elles
elles rejettent du co2 à la fabrication
il faut faire fondre du silicium pour
faire des panneaux solaires
on utilise beaucoup de béton très
émetteurs de co2 pour faire tenir les
éoliennes droite quand il ya du vent
le point commun de toutes ces énergies
bas carbone c'est qu'elles produisent de
l'électricité l'électricité c'est le
vecteur de la transition énergétique
moi je suis ingénieur en électricité
j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans l'énergie
d'ailleurs mes parents disaient que j'en
avais beaucoup à revendre j'ai commencé
ma carrière dans le nucléaire au sein du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
pendant une vingtaine d'années et puis
j'ai eu la chance d'être embauché dans
un laboratoire solaire mon job c'était
d'expertisé les systèmes photovoltaïques
pour le compte du gouvernement français
partout dans le monde
j'ai voyagé dans des endroits
magnifiques ya pire comme job mais c'est
là que j'ai touché du doigt l'importance
du stockage pour les énergies
renouvelables mais pas seulement
le problème avec les énergies
renouvelables
c'est leur principal défaut c'est
qu'elles sont intermittentes
ça veut dire qu'il ya un risque qu'elles
ne produisent plus quand on en a besoin
ou quelles qu'elles produisent trop
quand on en a plus besoin
alors pour ajuster les courbes de
production et de consommation
il faut être capable de stocker
l'électricité c'est le rôle des
batteries c'est un enjeu majeur pour
notre futur que ce soit pour les
énergies renouvelables ou pour la
mobilité
je vous le dis le stockage de
l'électricité
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité en parlant
d' humanité je me souviens c'était en
indonésie on était perdus ou en plein
milieu de la jungle et on installer un
système solaire en plein cagnard on
manipulait des batteries au carbone et
batteries au plomb plein d'acide et il
fallait les protéger des enfants pour
pas qu'ils brûlent c'était pas facile
mais j'ai eu la chance d'actionner le
disjoncteur du village le soir et je
peux vous dire que quand j'ai vu le
visage de ces personnes qui ne
connaissaient pas du tout l'électricité
s'illuminer lorsque tous les lampadaires
se sont allumés c'était magique c'était
la fête au village
c'est là que vous vous rendez compte que
l'énergie ça peut rendre heureux
alors j'ai toujours gardé un petit peu
de cette lumière au fond de moi dans
tout ce que j'ai fait après cette
expérience au milieu des années 90 une
nouvelle technologie de batteries est
arrivée qui ont remplacé les batteries
au plomb sont les batteries au lithium
elles ont plus d'énergie elles sont plus
légères plus compact les inventeurs des
batteries au lithium ont été récompensés
du prix nobel de chimie en 2019 voyez
c'est très récent et les batteries au
lithium sont en pleine expansion
aujourd'hui il y a dix ans on produisait
les batteries lithium essentiellement
pour les ordinateurs et les téléphones
portables
aujourd'hui on produit cinq fois plus de
batterie 75% de ses batteries vont dans
des véhicules électriques et ses
véhicules électriques ne représente que
2% du parc mondial automobile
vous imaginez le nombre de batteries qui
va falloir produire quand on va vouloir
passer à 50% de véhicules électriques
c'est monstrueux la commission
européenne estime que d'ici 2030 pour
répondre à la demande des véhicules
électriques
il va falloir mettre en service entre 45
et 90 usines géantes de batteries ses
usines géantes
on les appelle des gigas factory et là
vous avez une illustration de la giga
factory numéro 4 de tesla qui se trouve
à côté de berlin dans une magnifique
forêt ils ont été obligés de couper 300
hectares d'arbres pour fabriquer ses
batteries
il faut des métaux qui sont rares ou qui
vont le devenir comme le manganèse le
cobalt ou le cuivre
elles sont difficiles à recycler et on
passe plus de temps à les recharger qu'à
les utiliser
je vois que vous avez fait cette
expérience aussi et qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ce cas là et on en prend plusieurs
on se rend pas compte de l'impact
carbone des batteries au lithium
aujourd'hui une et une méta étude
suédoise a été publié en 2020 basé sur
40 articles scientifiques
il ya montré que un kilowattheure de
batteries lithium
c'est à dire à peu près une batterie de
5 à 10 kg et mettait entre 150 et 250 kg
de co2 dans l'atmosphère
dix fois leur poids oui j'ai bien dit kg
c'est énorme
une tesla ses 75 kilowattheure ça veut
dire qu'elle aimait entre 11 et 18
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère à rien
que pour la batterie bon heureusement
même cette tesla
elle va finalement à l' usage au bout de
quatre ans émettre moins de co2 qu'une
voiture thermique
mais quand même c'est gigantesque le
comble c'est que dans une batterie
lithium
il n'y a pas beaucoup de lithium il ya
beaucoup plus de carbone
alors aux environs des années 2000 dans
le milieu des années 2000 lorsque les
nanotechnologies ont émergé je me suis
intéressé plus particulièrement aux
nouvelles formes de carbone les carbone
à l'échelle nanométrique
on a découvert à ce moment là que le
carbone pouvait prendre d'autres formes
que le graphique ou le diamant on a
parlé de fûts les rênes on a parlé de
nanotubes de carbone on a parlé de
graphène
ce sont des matériaux avec des
propriétés remarquables là aussi il ya
eu des prix nobel et les opportunités
pour fabriquer des batteries était
gigantesque
alors j'ai sauté le pas un peu comme si
les puzzles de ma carrière
professionnelle
ça semblait tout de manière idéale les
énergies renouvelables le solaire le
carbone les nanotechnologies l'humanité
et j'ai décidé de créer une entreprise
pour fabriquer des batteries pour les
énergies renouvelables et pour les
véhicules électriques
mais pas n'importe quelle batterie des
batteries qui font la part belle au
carbone alors les batteries au carbone
que l'on développe elle se recharge en
quelques minutes elles durent longtemps
elles n'ont pas ou peu besoin de métaux
rares pour leur fabrication
elle consomme moins d'eau et moins de
produits chimiques pour les fabriquer on
utilise un procédé durable et éco
circulaire qui vise à utiliser des
matières premières bio sur sable comme
par exemple de l'huile de plantes ou
d'arbres qu'on cultiverait de manière
durable
ou alors du co2 directement qu'on
viendrait capter dans les fumées des
usines polluantes ou directement dans
l'atmosphère
mon graal ce serait de fabriquer des
batteries au carbone sans utiliser de
mines et en réduisant les déchets
alors ok aujourd'hui on a pris
l'habitude avec nos voitures de pouvoir
faire jusqu'à 1000 km si on voulait
faire la même chose avec des voitures
électriques
il faudrait mettre des grosses batteries
polluantes je pense que il est aussi
très intéressant de développer des
batteries légères et rapides
je vais vous prendre un exemple
réfléchissons ensemble une voiture
aujourd'hui par 95% du temps elle est à
l'arrêt 5 % du temps quand elles roulent
dans 95% du temps elle va faire moins de
50 km y a pas besoin d'une grosse
batterie pour ça si on utilisait des
batteries au carbone ultra rapide on
pourrait augmenter l'utilisation de
notre véhicule de manière plus intensive
plus efficace et plus répétitives
on pourrait récupérer l'énergie au
freinage la restituer à l'accélération
on pourrait si on partage les véhicules
recharger plus facilement entre deux
entre deux personnes entre deux usages
alors allez vous allez me dire pour ça
il va falloir multiplier les bornes de
recharge
c'est vrai mais techniquement rien ne
m'empêche par exemple de recharger une
voiture électrique sur le compteur
électrique extérieur de votre maison sur
le trottoir il ya un potentiel de plus
de 30 millions de bornes de recharge
quasiment instantanément et pas cher en
plus ça ferait du revenu d'activité en
france et ce serait exceptionnel
révolutionnaire pour les transports en
commun mais on peut voir encore plus
loin l'électricité c'est extrêmement
flexible ça c'est change très vite
on pourrait très bien imaginer que les
voitures se rechargent les unes les
autres
fini le coup de la panne et qui sait ça
pourrait créer de nouveaux emplois
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie oh moi
je suis chauffeur chargeur électrique
je conduis un gros camion électrique
avec une grosse batterie au carbone
derrière et je recharge toutes les
voitures qui veulent bien se connecter
en roulant à fond à mon camion
bah c'est super il ya même des projets
qui visent à développer des routes qui
recharge directement les voitures en
continu
sans contact par induction c'est plus
1000 kilomètres qu'on va pouvoir faire
c'est le tour de la terre d'une seule
traite
bon ok j'arrête
peut-être que je rêve un petit peu trop
mais c'est vrai on est à l'aube d'une
nouvelle ère en termes de mobilité
raymond devos le disait bien en france
on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a des
idées lui avait décidé de troquer sa de
chevaux pour une de boeuf mais il avait
bien raison l'humoriste aujourd'hui on a
de moins en moins de pétrole
donc il va falloir avoir de plus en plus
d'idées et moi je pense très
profondément
comme nicolas bouzou que l'innovation
sauvera le monde
c'est pour ça que je pousse cette idée
de batteries au carbone plus
respectueuse de l'environnement
et vous êtes vous prêts à changer vos
modes de déplacement êtes vous prêt à
trouver les solutions qui sont plus
durable plus respectueuse de
l'environnement plus électrique plus
rapide merci beaucoup
[Musique]